maman je peux savoir ce que tu fais rien
je bouquine top tu a grignoté la poutre
maman est en train de péter une durite
ici alors il faut que je sorte et je
sais que tu as peur que je fasse une
autre victime
mais il faut que tu pense à toutes ces
personnes que je n'ai pas tué c'est à
dire tous les habitants de cette planète
sauf trois personnes je crois que tu
devrais te montrer plus discrète en
attendant de savoir ce qui se passe je
vais faire semblant et jouer à
l'ancienne celle à celle qui est
charmant et humide et qui n'est jamais
lu d'orgasme en avalant le foie d'un
être humain
je trouve que notre salle d'abattage
ressemble trop à une salle d'abattage
oui on dirait qu'on s'est inspiré d'une
vraie salle d'abattage
c'est vous qui avez fait ça des morceaux
aimant retrouver autour de rock épique
tard tu pourrais vraiment bien que de
nombreuses personnes disparaissent de
santa clarita ces derniers temps s'est
débarrassé d'un flic et maintenant tu
fais rentrer un autre flic dans notre
vie il devient de plus en plus agressive
aussi ça peut empirer
ça risque d'être encore plus je t'aime
et on peut compter l'un sur l'autre
le reste n'a aucune importance [ __ ]
c'est quoi ce foutoir
j'aimerais passer rien qu'une journée où
il n'est pas question de vie ou de mort
tu verra plus tard si tu as des enfants
et que tu chopes un virus qui te force à
tuer des gens tu apprécieras ce qu'on
fait à mère et moi
je veux savourer la merde rêver plus
grands je ne vais pas arrêter de vivre
parce que je suis morte vivante à merde
remet moi de te découvrir l'origine de
ce mal pour que ça n'arrive plus à faire
ce qu'on va sauver le monde et c'est pas
possible aujourd'hui quoi on doit
jongler avec tellement de choses
le plus gros projet de notre carrière
bas à quoi servira le développement
immobilier quand des armées basse as un
bon genre d'homme parcourront la ville
je trouve que tous les deux on a
d'excellents arguments à mon avis n'ont
pas tous les deux
[Musique]
les bateaux j'avais lu
je suis tellement désolé aucune famille
n'est parfaite
qui cherche un petit ventre pour le
connais du travail
salut alors ça boume je m'appelle garé à
aujourd'hui